[Musique]
toute l'actualité du continent africain
c'est maintenant sur France 24 ravi de
vous retrouver pour votre journal de
l'Afrique au sommaire ce soir 20 ans de
prison le verdictée est tombé pour
Laurent boutibaruta l'ancien préfère
rwandais reconnu coupable d'avoir
participé au massacre de civil Tutsi
Denis muque Candida à la présidentielle
congolaise de 2023 des intellectuels
fait de la cause du gynécologue Nobel de
la Paix l'un d'entre eux et notre invité
le Malawi relocalise plusieurs centaines
d'éléphants dans l'un de ses parcs
nationaux l'objectif est double
préserver une espèce menacée et lutter
contre le braconnage
l'accusation avait requis la perpétuité
la cour d'assise de Paris condamne
Laurent potimaruta à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle l'ancien préfère rwandais
reconnu coupable de complicité de
génocide et complicité de crimes contre
l'humanité il a été acquitté pour
génocide Antoine
c'était le 9 mai dernier assis sur une
chaise roulante Laurent butsy barrouta
se présente à l'ouverture de ce procès
cette ex préfère rwandais est jugée pour
son rôle dans le génocide de la minorité
toutes si en 1994 l'ancien fonctionnaire
âgé aujourd'hui de 78 ans à une nouvelle
fois clamer son innocence
je n'ai jamais été dans le camp des
tueurs je veux dire au rescapés du
génocide qu'il ne m'est jamais venu à
l'esprit de les abandonner au tueur
est-ce par manque de courage est-ce que
je pouvais les sauver ce sont des
questions qui me hante depuis plus de 28
ans à l'époque des faits Laurent
boutibarruta dirigeait la préfecture de
King kongoro au sud du pays l'accusation
le juge responsable de 4 massacres dans
cette région pour les parties civils
sont inaction à l'époque vos
culpabilités il est quand même
responsable d'avoir fait rassembler tous
les taux de ci dans ces lieux en
particulier à molenbee soi-disant pour
les protéger or ils n'ont jamais été
protégés et comme on l'a vu dans
d'autres procès ces lieux de
rassemblement ont toujours été suivis de
massacres entre avril et juillet 1994 le
génocide dont a été victime une grande
majorité de toutes ci a fait au moins
800 000 morts
libération immédiate c'est ce que
demande au Mali la Côte d'Ivoire
concernant ses 49 soldats étaient à
l'aéroport de Bamako les autorités
maliennes les considèrent comme des
mercenaires ils ont été transférés à la
justice Abidjan assure de son côté que
c'est militaire venaient en appui
logistique à la mission de la minusma la
force de maintien de la paix de l'ONU
l'enquête à avance en Afrique du Sud
deux hommes ont été arrêtés ils sont
suspectés d'avoir ouvert le feu le
week-end dernier dans un bar de Peter
Maryse Berg dans l'est du pays quatre
personnes sont mortes pour l'autre
fusillade qui a eu lieu également dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche 7 fois dans
une taverne de Johannesburg la police
recherche 5 individus là les assaillants
ont tué 15 clients de l'établissement
des problèmes de coeur et une
surinfection pulmonaire l'autopsie de
joséduardo Dos Santos a livré ses
premiers résultats l'ancien président
angolais décédé vendredi à Barcelone
serait donc bien mort naturellement
l'examen avait été demandé par l'une de
ses filles qui avaient des doutes quant
aux raisons du décès de son père il
était hospitalisé en Espagne depuis le
ventre juin après un arrêt cardiaque
levez-vous pour prendre la tête de ce
peuple meurtri présentez-vous à
l'élection présidentielle de 2023 c'est
par ces mots que 15 intellectuels
congolais appelle le docteur Denis muku
egué à être candidat à la fonction
suprême en RDC le gynécologue a gagné
ses lettres de noblesse en réparant les
femmes victimes de violences sexuelles
sont pris sa Caroff en 2014 son Nobel de
la paix en 2018 lui ont donné une
renommée internationale l'un des
signatures de cette tribune et avec nous
ce soir de passage à Paris bonjour
Alphonse mundo bonjour vous êtes
politologue enseignant à l'université de
kizombani dans le nord-est de la RD
Congo merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation
de France 24 être chirurgien prix Nobel
de la paix qui plus est ne fait pas pour
autant de Denis moko gay un bonhomme
politique pourquoi selon vous doit-il se
présenter pourquoi a-t-il la carrure
d'un homme d'état vous savez les
lorsqu'on regarde beaucoup de gens ont
tendance à à considérer mon collègue
comme un simple médecin ce n'est pas que
c'est d'abord quelqu'un et qui c'est un
homme de fois un homme d'action
quelqu'un qui qui croit ce qu'il fait et
qui fait ce que c'est encore il croit
donc on est là face à quelqu'un qui a
l'habitude de faire et des corps en ce
qu'il fait et ensuite le docteur
denimokuge c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
ses preuves en termes de de de mise en
place et de mise en oeuvre de beaucoup
de programmes de de de de développement
d'économie
ils ont mis en place des systèmes
sociaux économiques solidaires et et
chaque année beaucoup de gens ne savent
peut-être pas mais nous qui le côtoyons
nous savons que chaque année il y a au
moins 20 000 personnes qui profitent qui
sont donc appuyées par le travail
docteur Denis pour être autonome pour
pouvoir vivre dignement pour pouvoir
gagner leur vie et et le docteur Denis
même si on regardait ce moment du point
de vue de 2 mètres que fait un médecin
le travail d'un médecin c'est d'abord de
faire un diagnostic et ensuite une fois
que vous avez fait le diagnostics si de
faire de de faire de pouvoir de
thérapies possible et ensuite de décider
d'une thérapie et après maintenant vous
allez commencer à revoir la thérapie
jusqu'à ce que les maladies c'est
exactement ce qu'on attend d'un homme
politique un homme politique c'est
quelqu'un qui doit être capable de
d'analyser la situation de son pays et
de pouvoir faire de regarder les
solutions possibles que dans décider et
d'une et ensuite d'essayer de mettre en
oeuvre et de faire des adaptations
nécessaires et cela le docteur mon
compte il est fait au quotidien alors
justement face à ce diagnostic dont vous
parlez quelle est la thérapie qu'on
envisagerait le docteur
pour sauver finalement si je vous
entends bien la RD Congo aujourd'hui
voilà c'est c'est très important pour le
docteur moko le docteur moko est il veut
qu'il y ait un changement profond dans
ces pays et c'est ce qu'il a toujours
fait quand vous lisez toutes ces
déclarations quand vous l'écoutez et
dernièrement vous avez vu ce qui s'est
passé à Kinshasa lorsque il il y a des
gens qui commençaient à se promener avec
de machettes qu'on appelle des
tramontinents et qui qui cherchait du
rwandais pour le massacrer on a vu là un
homme responsable et qui voit le
problème et qui essaie de trouver une
solution à ça il a appelé en lingala
tous les Chinois à ne pas suivre ses
appels à la haine ces appels à olymphage
au massage de gens dans la vie de
Kinshasa et il a été suivi et là c'est
un nombre d'État c'est un véritable chef
d'État qui a parlé mais vous et il a été
suivi et donc c'est cet homme là et qui
a donc ses compétences et qui a montré
ses preuves et euh et qui aussi ouais
vous et qui a qui a aussi un leadership
et une vision et et qui a militaire qui
milite pour une juste transitionnelle et
qui tire beaucoup domaines et quand vous
parlez avec lui nous qui le côtoyons au
quotidien on voit que c'est une
véritable encyclopédie mais aussi un
homme pragmatique
qui n'a pas seulement de connaissance
moi je suis de Sciences Po mais quand je
discute avec lui je me sens très à
l'aise il comprend mon langage et il
essaie de parler et donc et c'est ce
qu'il fait avec d'autres collègues
d'économie aussi c'est quelqu'un qui a
donc une vision et qui a un leadership
et pour nous il faut que ce type d'homme
et qui ne veut pas le pouvoir pour le
pouvoir et qui veut un changement
profond et c'est pour ça que c'est
essentiel que dans cette quête de
pouvoir pour un changement profond et
non pas avoir seulement la présence il
faut que ceux qui se reconnaissent dans
cet appel que nous avons lancé nous
avons lancé qui s'organise à tous les
niveaux au niveau national au niveau des
provinces des territoires tout ça qui
croient en ce message ici et qui
s'organise en cellule pour se mettre
près pour pouvoir porter ses messages de
changement dont nous avons besoin alors
justement vous l'avez rappelé vous êtes
proche de lui est-ce qu'il est au
courant de votre démarche comment il
réagit parce qu'on le rappelle c'est pas
la première fois en 2018 déjà certains
Congolais voulaient le voir incarner
cette transition sans sans Kabila à
l'époque là est-ce qu'il a lui cette
ambition politique alors vous savez ça
c'est une décision personnelle mais mais
nous euh le connaissant le côtoyant au
quotidien
prenne en charge merci beaucoup merci
pardonnez-moi c'est tout le temps qui
qui nous est un parti va malheureusement
on pourrait en parler évidemment des
heures à faire à suivre en tout cas
puisque l'élection présidentielle en RD
Congo ce sera en 2023 on verra donc ici
Denis vous a entendu cet appel merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous de France
24 ce soir cet espoir à présent venu du
Kenya un million et demi de personnes
vivent avec le sida un nouveau
traitement étant en phase d'essai
clinique une solution injectable qui
combine des entrées rétroviraux plus
simple d'utilisation plus discrète aussi
Laurent Berchet
cela fait plus de 20 ans que benta
agolla a contracté le VIH chaque jour à
la même heure elle doit ingérer un
mélange de comprimés un traitement à vie
qu'elle ne peut pas dissimuler à ses
proches
ça n'a pas été facile je dois avoir mes
médicaments sur moi tout le temps et
m'assurer de les prendre chaque jour
nombre de passions sont découragés par
cet effort quotidien qui les oblige à
dévoiler leur maladie mais un nouveau
traitement à base d'injection pourrait
bientôt changer la donne
ça pourrait pousser les gens qui sont
malades et qui le cachent à suivre un
traitement beaucoup ont peur de se
soigner à cause de la discrimination
dont ils font l'objet
par les autorités sanitaires américaines
et britanniques en début d'année est
actuellement en essai clinique au Kenya
en Ouganda et en Afrique du Sud il
consiste en une simple piqûre à
renouveler tous les deux mois un procédé
plus simple mais surtout plus discret
que les traitements classiques
il faut prendre des médicaments tous les
jours et cela fatigue et ça décourage
beaucoup de passion il y a aussi
beaucoup de stigmatisation autour du VIH
environ un million et demi de Kenyans
sont positifs au VIH mais seuls les deux
tiers se soignent avec des médicaments
les scientifiques espèrent que ce
nouveau traitement à base d'injection
sera convaincre les 500.000 personnes
restantes
le Malawi vient en aide aux éléphants
menacés pour empêcher la disparition
d'une espèce 250 pachides vont être
relaxés relocalisés dans le parc
national du kassongu troisième opération
de sauvetage en trois ans et vous allez
le voir le défi et le taille cabinet
il ne le sait pas encore mais pour cet
éléphant c'est le début d'une nouvelle
vie originaire du parc national de
lewandais au sud-est du Malawi comme
plus de 200 de ses congénères il sera
endormi avant d'être transporté jusqu'au
parc de Gaston Go à des centaines de
kilomètres au nord une mesure nécessaire
pour protéger un fragile équilibre
écologique selon le dirigeant
nous voulons réduire la population
d'éléphants dans le parc de lewandais
car actuellement nous en avons plus de
600 pour préserver l'écologie du parc il
faudrait plutôt avoir autour de 300
bêtes
ce programme gouvernemental visa réduire
le nombre de confrontations entre hommes
animaux aux conséquences parfois
mortelles les éléphants auront plus de
place dans leur nouvelle environnement
et n'auront plus besoin d'aller chercher
de la nourriture dans les villages
voisins les riverains près du parc de
limondes sont soulagés de les voir
partir
je suis contente que des éléphants
soient relocalisés car il venait trop
souvent dans nos jardins et il
détruisait nos récoltes ils étaient trop
nombreux
malgré un oncle fermé et un système de
traquage la population locale
d'éléphants voit plus que triplés en
quelques semaines pendant les années 70
le parc compter plus de 1000 animaux
aujourd'hui malgré les efforts de
conservation ils sont seulement une
centaine d'individus
et voilà pour le journal de l'Afrique
édition à retrouver sur notre site
internet france 24.com le reste de
l'actu internationale c'est dans
quelques minutes reste avec nous
[Musique]